[Music]
all right dr mccurdy and anything else
there are a host more questions
pardon
now you said are there is there a host
oh no i mean like there there are
multiple other questions yes
there are a host of questions left
uh and i i don't think we'd be able to
cover them no we won't today what's the
next question pick one and i'll answer
it i'll try it out i'll pick one
an easy one
oh wow i just pressed on one and i don't
know if this is easy over but
it's well it's even two can the devil
manipulate our dreams
and
the second part is is it better to pray
silently or out loud because we know
that satan doesn't read our minds
well that's not too bad let's pray our
father in heaven as we continue to
answer questions speak through us i pray
please in jesus name amen
dreams are affected by what you see
during the day and by other other
components i imagine
i can't say yes or no i do know the
devil affects the mind he tries to play
on the mind and the minds cannot be
separated from dreams
so we have to be sure
that during the day our mind is resting
the right place
i have dreamt about things that i saw
earlier in the day that event affected
my dream or popped up in my dream it
really has i have dreamed about things i
was thinking about and then i dreamt
about it i'm not saying i can control my
dreams i'm simply saying how what we
allow into our minds can have an effect
on what pops up in the dream world
so i can't say the devil can directly
tell you what to dream or determine your
dreams or implant dreams into your head
but association with him can certainly
affect the quality of the dreams
so what i suggest to people is this
fill your minds with that which is
righteous
all day
and the last thing at night on your mind
should be christ
our high calling i believe this is page
116 ell white rice your last thought at
night your first thought in the morning
should be of him of whom is centered
your hope of eternal life
so go to bed with christ on the mind
with this verse first john 3 8
for this purpose the son of god was
manifested that he might destroy the
works of the devil father whatever
citizen is trying to do now destroy it
just try it go to sleep with god as the
last thing on your mind because the fact
that you're sleeping doesn't mean the
devil is sleeping
uh as for praying
as far as possible pray quietly as far
as possible
so the devil doesn't know what you're
praying for or praying about one of the
reasons why i preach the right priest i
don't want the devil to know what i'm
going to say
so he can go to someone's house and keep
that person from coming because he knows
i'm talking about the second coming
otherwise the devil looks over the
shoulder of the preacher to see what
he's preparing and then goes and keeps
someone from coming she writes that so i
do everything up here so he cannot see
now he may guess when he sees what
champions i'm looking at but he cannot
see exactly what i'm about to talk about
so he doesn't really know who to keep
away from the sermon
and so pray quietly is my recommendation
um but there's a time to pray out loud
sometimes i do pray out loud so he can
hear me
mm-hmm
did you hear me when jesus rebuked him
he then rebuked him quietly he breaks
him out loud
so there's a time to pray out loud but
most of the time have it pretty silently
so the devil does not know what you're
saying or what you're asking for
whatever he doesn't know
he doesn't know everything he can read
your face but he doesn't know
but so can your parents
so he doesn't know everything